welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session on
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain I'd like to introduce dr.
Jennifer colander she is an assistant
professor in the department of physical
medicine and rehabilitation at the
university of pittsburgh she's also a
research biomedical engineer in the VA
R&D center of excellence she will be
presenting in our brain initiative
scientific updates track on influence of
task context on motor cortical activity
during reaching and grasping for
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
usually my name is dr. Sneha Shannon and
I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth we would like to extend our
special thanks to the brain initiative
program directors in particular dr.
James mad for their efforts in
organizing today's session before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting questions during the
presentation so we'll click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type a question into the
drop-down box we will also be offering
the unique opportunity to directly
address awardees of the research on
humans division of the brandish'd
this slide man'll Q&A will take place
today at 9 a.m. Pacific time 12:00 p.m.
Eastern Time
any questions that we don't have time to
address to our speakers will be
forwarded by an email following the
presentation dr. calendars presentation
is educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to opinion credits
now without further ado please join me
in welcoming dr. Jennifer colander okay
thank you to labyrinth and NIH for
having me here today to talk to you
about the influence of test context on
motor cortex activity during reaching
and grasping so first I want to explain
to you the system within which we are
conducting these experiments so we're
using a bite of our
shall brain computer interface or BCI is
I'll use throughout my talk and so you
see is the brain of the left the
recording activity from motor cortex
shown there in blue turning that into a
control signal for robotic arm or hand
and at the same time using sensors in
that robot to send some three feedback
back to this meta sensory cortex shown
in red through stimulation and
electrodes that are implanted into the
brain and so here we have this nice
closed loop system where we have a full
characterization of the neurons that are
contributing to motor control as well as
the somatosensory feedback that the
person is receiving and so we can study
some three motor control within this
well-characterized system and I won't
talk too much today about the sensory
feedback part of this system but my
colleague Rob Kahn who's been leading
this component of the work and will be
on the live Q&A if you have any
questions about that part so to talk
about the recording side as I mentioned
we have electrode arrays that are
implanted into motor cortex you can see
a picture of it at the bottom left of
the screen there's about a hundred
electrodes that penetrate a millimeter
and a half into the cortex and allow us
to record from single neurons or small
groups of neurons that are nearby the
tip of the electrode if you look at the
footprint or recordings from one of
these arrays you see there's about a
hundred rectangles there each one is
recordings from a single channel on that
array and if you zoom into one of these
channels what you see is that we can
actually by setting up threshold record
action potentials or threshold crossings
from neurons that are nearby the tip of
the electrode and the firing rate of
these neurons is what we use to actually
control the brain computer interface the
way that we do this is actually based on
work that really began in the 1980s I
was discovered by George Ellis and
Schwartz for example so in their
experiment they were recording from the
motor cortex of monkeys who are reaching
to targets arranged in different
directions spaced around a circle in the
workspace so when they looked at the
firing rates of these neurons I'm
showing you here raster plots each
grouping of classes four reaches to a
different target direction and every
time you see a black vertical line
that's a neuron firing and so what you
see is that the monkey who when he was
reaching
to the left that neuron was firing a lot
and when they were reaching the opposite
direction of its fire learning really
not at all so if you plot the firing
rate of that neuron versus the direction
of movement it actually resembles a
cosine function and so you can write a
linear equation to explain the
relationship between firing rate s here
and the movement velocity in the X and y
direction so it's a pretty simple
relationship to characterize the
relationship between neural activity and
movement and what we've done within our
human BCI studies it's really to scale
this up to include additional dimensions
so the equation that we often use to
explain that movement kinematics is
shown here where the firing rate of a
neuron is assumed to be explained by
translation velocity shown here at the X
py and PZ the orientation velocity an
extrinsic space for the theta X theta Y
Zeta Z and we also use grasp aperture
velocity so in this case it's a seven
dimensional control signal and when we
combine recordings from neurons
throughout motor cortex we can actually
use that to enable simultaneous and
continuous control of all of the
specified dimensions so here as I
mentioned seven dimensional control the
way that we calibrate our system is
different from what I just showed you
and that our participants typically have
paralysis of their upper limbs and so
they can't perform an earth movement and
so we rely on a virtual environment and
have them attempt to do these different
movements so across the top I'm showing
you an example trial where the person is
thinking about controlling that virtual
robotic arm that you see at the left
they're given a target shown in red they
need to reach to that target grasp it
and then carry it to the new location
shown as a green plane in the workspace
and then release it when instructed so
the way we do this is first by an
observation phase or the participant
watches that task happening being
controlled by the computer thinking
about attempting to perform that
movement and we fit that initial model
of firing rate to movement kinematics
then we give the participant control
over the virtual system and perform a
closed loop
refinement while we have some some error
clamping on in order to reduce error so
once we have that that's what the end up
using for the rest of the test session
to control the arm we found that it was
important to include virtual objects
into our calibration paradigm in order
for that to translate to successful
control with a real robotic arm and I'll
talk a little bit about that a little
bit later we also found that it was
important to randomly sample different
movement combinations and behavioral
states so being able to reach without an
object and also carry an object was
important and importantly even in our
participant to have paralysis
I'm just attempting to perform these
movements with the virtual arm generates
start similar neural activity to what
has been seen in able-bodied non-human
primate participants during during overt
movements and so that gives us a nice
confidence that we know what we're
actually using for motor control is
really biomimetic and mimicking what is
observed during the first movement I'll
be talking to you today about results
from to study participants who have
participated under an fda
investigational device exemption the
first was a 52 year old woman it's a
time of device implant she had fine a
cerebellar degeneration that resulted in
motor paralysis essentially from the
neck down she had to 96 channel
electrode arrays that were implanted
into motor cortex a device is shown
right below on the left and our second
participant was a 28 year old man at the
time of implant
he had a c5 c6 a to be incomplete spinal
injuries that he did have some proximal
arm function was unable to move his hand
with weakness in his wrist and elbow and
he had 288 channel arrays that were
implanted into motor cortex and 232
channel arrays is not a sensory cortex
the device was such that there was a
single external pedestal connector for
each pair of recording arrays that went
into motor cortex and stimulation arrays
that when it's a somatosensory cortex so
first I will summarize briefly on some
of the results from the inter critical
micro stimulation studies and this work
was conducted initially by charlene
Fletcher a former graduate student in
the lab it's what I'm showing you in the
left is a picture of a hand that we
showed the participant as we stimulated
individual electrodes in random orders
and throughout the course of the study
he would report to us where a
stimulation on a single electrode felt
like it was coming from on his own hands
and so you see we have coverage of parts
of each of the four fingers
and if you look at the spatial
arrangement on their right you can see
that there's structure there so in the
middle panel you're seeing the central
sulcus represented as a vertical red
line and then you see the - or electrode
arrays as a schematics to the right of
that and so there's one or electrode
arrays it's more medial and one that's
more lateral and so in each of those
each square is representing an electrode
only the white or colored ones are
actually electrically connected so it
used to use a stimulation of the medial
electrodes it's generating stations on
the little finger and then it moves to
the ring and then the middle and then
the index finger goes laterally and so
what we know is that it's not a sensory
cortex there is a not a topic
representation that's very highly
ordered in the normal intact brain and
so what we see is that even after 10
years of spinal injury stimulation
through these electrode arrays still
generates sensations that follow that
expected somatic topic representation
with a little finger most medial and the
index finger most lateral so again this
gives us confidence that this Madison
Street feedback that we're providing is
in at least some sense biomimetic in
that the natural circuitry is still
preserved after spinal cord injury so
I'm going to switch gears for the rest
of the talk and talk mostly about the
motor control side so this work was
initially done by John Downey a former
graduate student in the lab and what he
observed when our participant was using
the brain computer interface is that
sometimes they would have difficulty
interacting with objects so while they
can move the arm around in space very
well once there was an object that our
control tended to degrade so he designed
a simple experiment where the goal is
either to reach to that red object shown
at the the left picture reach to that
particular position and then cue to
grasp that object or he the participant
needed to reach to the same point in
space and then grasp and close the hand
even though there was no object there
and so what you see on the bottom is
just her lots of performance when using
the BCI when we don't correct for this
difference in context and you see that
the participants are much more
successful when there was no object in
the workspace and when the cylinder was
there and even when they were successful
the completion times were a little bit
faster when the object was in the
workspace so a really high-level look at
the neural
grace tells us as shown on the right
that the distribution of firing rates as
compared to what we observed during
calibration is higher when there is an
object in the workspace and it's much
more variable as well as compared to the
no object case and so looking a little
bit more closely I'm going to show you
the single channel recordings are
showing sensitivity to object presence
so let me orient you to this figure so
results from subject 1 are shown across
the top and subject to across the bottom
and the x-axis of each plot is showing
the time relative to 2 reaching the
target so this is actually during the
reach phase about a second and a half
prior to contacting the object the color
is representing the firing rate of a
particular channel and so each row is
showing the firing rate for a given
channel on the electrode array and so
our red is representing an increase in
firing rate as compared to what we saw
during calibration and blue is showing a
decrease and so the first column is
showing you the firing rates as the
participants are reaching toward an
object so you see that there are
increases and decreases which makes
sense because we're moving always to the
left is some kind of jump in line with
the preferred direction sometimes it's
not but you also start to see that there
are some neurons that are firing a lot
more towards the end of that reach in
the no object case the distribution is
fairly equal between units that are
increasing or decreasing their firing
light but the most interesting causes on
the right where we take the difference
of firing rates for a given electrode
tuned to an object versus reaching in an
empty workspace and so we've sorted all
of these plots by the magnitude of that
difference at the end and so you can see
for both participants about two thirds
of the population is showing a strong
increase during that last 500
milliseconds of reach it actually
continues on to graph you know when
there is an object in the workspace so
this is really interesting to us because
even though the movement kinematics are
essentially the same just the presence
of that objects in the workspace is
causing some contextual information to
be represented in some motor cortex and
so that's one of our main focuses of our
nih funding that we we just started is
to really understand what is it about
the task because it is driving this
change so is it an expectation of
sensory speed
that the participant is going to be
getting an object content is it a change
in motor control scheme so stiffening or
making that the arm left rigid as
they're interacting with an object and
so we want to try to perturb particular
aspects of the task to understand
exactly what is causing this change in
firing rate moving on to another
experiment conducted by John Downey
again we wanted to move up from just
controlling kinematics of the arm into
controlling kinetics so could we see if
there was grasped force information
represented into motor court in motor
cortex so we started looking for this
using implicit force representations so
when you pick up an object such as those
pictured here a marshmallow tomato
orange or PMS soup you can grab this
with a consistent amount of force based
on your previous experience with Impa
with interacting with that object and so
we wanted to see if that information was
present in motor cortex of somebody with
chronic spinal cord injury so in this
experiment they were shown a picture of
one of these four objects and then cued
to grasp and then they were supposed to
think about attempting to grasp that
object with an appropriate amount of
force for two and a half seconds before
moving on to the next trial as a control
condition we just showed them the
picture of each of these objects and
then concentrate on it but did not
actually ask them to think about
grasping it and so on the bottom when
I'm showing you is our ability to
classify which object it was attempting
to graph or viewing based on the
recordings from motor cortex and so in
the perfect case we would see 100%
correct with with dark black boxes on
the diagonal and what you see on the
left is that when he's attempting to
grasp our prediction shown across the
bottom
you know matches pretty well with the
actual object that he was attempting to
grasp you know well above chance and
then when we did misclassify the object
it was always - an object of an adjacent
implicit force level so the marshmallow
might have been confused with the tomato
but not over the can of soup those are
very different in terms of his input the
course representation on the right for
the control condition just observing
these different objects didn't cause any
sort of patterned activity in motor
cortex that we were able to classify so
that was a chance level like we would
have expected in order to look a little
bit more at how the
was impacted by different contexts of
movement we essentially repeated our
calibration paradigm or the participant
was instructed to reach a virtual arm to
a target and space craft and transport
it to a new location but they were told
via audio cue to think about that red
object it's one of those four objects I
showed you on the previous slide and so
if we repeat that classification
analysis throughout the course of that
trial you see that even though you know
it's the identity of that object
throughout the trial we can really only
classify it above chance during the
active grasping chance and it disappears
during that transport case such as
attention shifts more to the kinematics
of the movement so that experiment
inspired a frantic lava current postdoc
in the lab to follow up on this and
really try to understand a little bit
more about what was going on with within
the neural signals and so he applied the
next principal component analysis to
that particular data set and D PCA
identifies dimensions within the neural
data that are related to different
components of the task and so what we
see here is that we can identify neural
States essentially that are
corresponding sequentially to different
elements of this task and so let me walk
you through each part of this slide in
order so across the top we have a neural
dimension that's really related to force
and so you see we finally selected the
two extreme force conditions for the can
of SIBO marshmallow at the high end low
force what you see is that you know when
they've reached the target and recued to
grasp we see clear separation and
transient separation related to the
onset of that graft force when they move
into the carry phase directional
information is strongly represented we
can separate the neural data separate
spaces on brothers are carrying to the
right or to the left and that graph
force component is no longer represented
there's also a transient component at
release that is not separable based on
the object that was seen crafts and put
the force representation or the
direction of carry consumer I wanted to
see if this was consistent across a
variety of different tasks I'll talk to
you about three of them today so in this
first we're just looking at force
application for crafts so again they
dude
a hand in virtual space and work you to
use either a soft or firm force to grasp
and hold the object and release it and
what we again see is that there is a
transient component in the neural space
that is happens right at the graph view
that separates based on the high or low
force instruction in this particular
task or they're explicitly instructed to
maintain a sort of particular force
value we do see that there is a separate
component in the neural state problem
state space that is separable based on
low or high force during that sustained
hold period and again we see a transient
release that is different from that
initial transient onset of grass closure
enforced in the second task it starts
very similar where they're cute to grasp
an object with a softer firm forest hold
it in grasp and then they're told to
adjust if they had a high force they
need to switch to a low force and a low
horsey to switch to a high force and
then they need to release and so what
was interesting here is that you see
that transient component that happens at
the initial grasp on set the during
grasp closure and initial object contact
again shows a transient component even
during the isometric change in fourth at
the adjust cue and as we might expect we
see that sustained force neural
dimension that switches directions after
the participant switch is their
intention of higher low force and for
both conditions we see the transient
release component at the end and similar
to that first experiment that I
described now we wanted to add a
transport component to the task and so
Brian looked at the neural dimensions
during a grasp and carry task so the
participant was instructed to grasp that
green object is a particular forest low
or high carry it to a new location and
release and similar to the previous two
experiments we again see this transient
component that is independent from to
sustained force component with a
transient release signal again so just
to summarize I hope that I've shown you
that after chronic spinal cord injury we
see that the neural activity that were
recording during attempted movement is
similar to that it's measured during the
heart movements and similarly in micro
stimulation of somatosensory cortex can
Matis topically organized sensations
that Felix are coming from individual
fingers even 10 years after chronic
spinal cord injury so again this gives
us a nice closed-loop well characterized
system within which the study sensory
motor control we have observed a lot of
context dependence in terms of the
neural activity so first we saw that
object presence impacts motor cortical
activity even when the movement
kinematics are the same we also found
that populous population level analyses
can reveal that there are neural
dimensions that are corresponding to
these different task states that are
sort of entered sequentially and that
they correspond to different conditions
such as the high and low force and
finally the brain computer interfaces
that we're developing you already use
and can benefit from an additional
understanding of sort of natural sensory
motor control in tact brain and we hope
to continue to study this further so I
would like to acknowledge the large team
of people that are working on this this
particular project including the the
postdocs of students that I've mentioned
throughout the talk in particular the
faculty collaborators here at Penn who's
been working on the BCI study in my
cottage or rock on Elizabeth telex para
a number of faculty collaborators both
Penn Carnegie Mellon University of
Chicago and their places and finally I'd
like to thank the study participants
that we really cannot do this with work
without their highly dedicated and spend
a lot of time with us really helping us
accomplish our studies and thank you to
NIH and DARPA for funding this work
thank you doctor colander for that very
informative presentation please remember
to submit your questions for dr.
colander who will answer them in the
light panel Q&A taking place at 9 a.m.
Pacific time and 12 p.m. Eastern Time
this is a unique opportunity to directly
address the awardees of the research on
humans division of the brain initiative
we look forward to seeing you there
coming up next dr. Samir Shah will
continue to Scientific updates of the
brain initiative with the presentation
on mechanisms of rapid flexible
cognitive control in human prefrontal
cortex